hey gang real quick before we get the
old show started let's talk about these
live days we got coming up
it's the keep it moving 2021 tour
and we're coming to a town near you
we're gonna be
in atlantic city new jersey june 18th oh
yeah and then we're gonna be in chicago
for our fourth and final show on june
22nd
then we're heading over to indianapolis
indiana
at the helium over there on june 23rd
get some tickets
and then we're coming back thursday
night back to the windy city
for two sold out shows so if you heard a
date on there
that wasn't sold out buy some tickets
and come see us
it's gonna be a great time yeah guys the
live show's awesome it's stand up and
then we play ayg
with the audience we answer your
questions it's a good [ __ ] time get
involved
see you there oh baby welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast
this is r u garbage sure is it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they grow up to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host states foley coming
at you on a rainy day
we're down here in antwerp started
raining nine seconds
it's a monsoon out there i tell ya my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me
uh-huh still uh living the key west
lifestyle over here ladies and gentlemen
give it up for kevin
james ryan hey gang happy to be here
thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate if
you subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are
true the roof true to [ __ ] roof and
then patreon.com you can sign up you get
bonus content you get episodes of ayg
you get episodes of a whole different
show hard feelings which is the show
behind the show
that's true a little bit uh it's me and
h foley the airing of the grievances
every week yes sir we got them you want
them
and then uh every month we'll do a live
stream
with our top tier members where we play
oig with you guys you play with us it's
a good [ __ ] time get involved and
also check out some [ __ ] live shows
we got chicago indy and atlantic city
coming up there you go
uh ac's almost sold out i think two
tables left as of today so let's go
let's round that out strong so whatever
you do if you see kippy kids don't buy
any weed off of them because this guy's
a cop
you've been pushing that and no one's
giving you anything he came in you're
like hey toby doesn't give you anything
god he's like no he doesn't look like a
cop
one of these days i'll get you with it
i'm telling you and how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man t-bone
mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what's up boys what's up
t-bone don't forget to mention the big
patreon weight loss challenge 500 bones
on the line for the big man to drive
which if you haven't been tuning in it's
a [ __ ]
wild ride let's just say that the town
is up
up is down who knows what the [ __ ]
going on kippy's got me upside down in a
weight loss contest
end up owing money but gang that is
neither here nor there because we could
not
be more excited to have our incredibly
special guest here with us today
our guest is a very funny stand-up
comedian actor
and writer as an actor she's appeared in
musee
you your brain and you westworld as a
writer
you're ready for this six nine episodes
of the jim jeffery show 26 episodes of
comedy knockout
she's appeared on gotham comedy live a
little late with lily singh
and she's one of the writers on the new
hulu summer hit
plan b yeah but the big question
i told you buddy's mine today is she
garbage
we're about to find out give it up for
one of our oldest palsy comedy
suba agarwal ladies and gentlemen hey
thank you for reading my entire imdb
page
holy [ __ ] yeah he gets into it i like it
he gets here an hour early he's like
nobody look at me and he's got like
he's got spreadsheets going he's doing
it all we're like we're like we're like
a high-end salon we're like a high-end
like place where you get a suit we want
you to feel good when you walk in the
door yeah we walked in we gave her a
warm nestle water so it's nice
we're the barber that gives you a glass
of scotch you know what i mean you get a
glass of champagne when you go to get
your hair down that's that's the way you
like to we're like everybody feeling
fresh
okay thank you for coming in and sitting
with us
yeah no thanks for having me i feel like
this is going to be an interesting one
let me ask you this
do you think you're garbage uh i think i
i have garbage qualities yeah for sure
1 000 at one point i did sleep
on a garbage bag so i feel like that's
that that's where i'm worried we're
going to get you
you're an extremely hard worker you've
been working very hard at comedy
you do things that that you know like
one of the things in this business is
are you prepared to do these things that
you have to do to get to the next level
and i'm sure you've crashed on some
couches you've done that how we met
was a little bit oh god i forgot how did
you meet
i don't think i know this story i never
met super before
all right and a friend of ours called
and said hey i was still in philly okay
i called and said hey
there's a comic friend of mine that's in
town she has a show tonight
she has nowhere to go between now and
then she's been on the road for like two
weeks
she's been wearing the same clothes
she's been sleeping
she's been sleeping and you let this
homeless person in your house
she's got a tight eight minutes on her
though can you let it can you let her in
to grab a shower and and throw a hot
meal after what
i swear to god that's dangerous i know
it's a miracle i'm not dead
i like i might because i got added to a
show last minute so like where i was
staying i didn't have anything lined up
but i was and i accepted the show
without another thought and then monroe
was like
you can shower and there's a fat guy in
south philly with a shower
can you be there in 10. she did not come
in on a limo i could tell you that
you took like a chinatown box 100 or the
mega bus oh my god but it all worked out
it was so great we had spaghetti we had
brownies with ice cream all these
leftovers from them yeah
leftovers i'm whipping up lunch if you
want to come in
yeah didn't you think it was strange i
was serving you spaghetti for lunch
who's the [ __ ] spaghetti bro i was so
excited for the spaghetti i was like
crazy dude i remember the first time i
met her
you did used to move through new york as
like a transient because you were doing
so many spots
you were like the person was like oh
super does 97.
like oh i regret all of it and i
remember you came in we were doing
i think it was point break or something
it was one of those weird midtown bars
that's like
nine floors and there was a show on like
the sixth one
and i remember i had just moved to new
york and like i was like feeling myself
i was pretty good and
i'm like you're like you bumped me
because you were like hey i got another
spot and they were like okay we're gonna
put suba up and then you like oh yeah
okay sure and then foley's like dude
she's gonna eat your lunch
and i'm like what do you mean dude
you're like dude she's a killer i'm like
this look get the [ __ ] out of the [ __ ]
what i'm [ __ ] good i'm a killer
dude she went up there i got up like two
minutes later i was like playing with
the microphone
i was sweating i couldn't get out of
that [ __ ] place quick enough you
unplugged the mic
on purpose oh yeah just trying to buy
yourself a couple of seconds
take a real long sip he's a killer folks
a killer
absolute killer so that's where my fears
come in that we're gonna
we're gonna get some dirt in it but i
have a feeling the upbringing school all
that stuff we're
we're going to find some some some class
there we'll see
are you from chicago originally suburbs
chicago
are we talking anywhere near the
mcallisters no
we well because my parents started out
right before i was born in an apartment
building and then they moved into a
smaller house in mondeline
and then eventually they moved into like
a nice house but
we couldn't afford that neighborhood but
my uncle owned a construction company
okay
so what we did was buy like a really
shitty plot of land that nobody wanted
like it was like covered in rocks and
[ __ ] it was impossible to grow anything
we'll take it
yeah and then my uncle built a house on
top of it at a discount for us so we
could go to a better school like
that's [ __ ] chess right there [ __ ]
that that's playing that's generational
moves
you could always tell the family that
couldn't quite afford to live in the
neighborhood
you know what i mean no lawn furniture
[ __ ] like that uh it was the [ __ ]
worst all those [ __ ] with their name
brand abercrombie and hollister that was
so furious
yeah you're going back to the shed on
the pile of rocks
wasn't it different than all the other
houses in the neighborhood
my uncle did a [ __ ] good job out of
the park oh yeah he hit that [ __ ] out
the park
an uncle contractor that's pretty good
yeah what did you what did your mom and
dad do
so my dad started off i'm pretty sure he
started off in construction i think
somebody told me that i'm not
i should probably call them more
what's going on no i think it was
construction that i started off and
that's how he ended up with that
horrific arm injury but he started off
wait what's up
yeah he like broke his arm and then
apparently they didn't know how to fix
it and then the bone healed wrong and
then there was one
trash thing when they're like they don't
know what they're doing they know what
they're doing that's why they're at the
hospital
but they had to like pull his arm like
in physical therapy it was like screwed
up but um
what yeah they were like oh it's not
going that way let's just pull on it and
then i think he ended up going to like
the mayo clinic or like somewhere
probably
his arm yeah that's for like cancer
that's a big jump in health care going
from a place where they're
where they're gonna fall in yeah the
pulling and stretching didn't work so
we're going to go to the
top shelf they literally have people
like holding them down like we're just
going to keep pulling your arms they're
like
what the [ __ ] how's the pulling
department
what's the co-pay on a stretch the mayo
clinic is where foley gets launched
that's the name of his kitchen
it did always confuse me as a kid i'm
not gonna lie
all right so but he started off there
and then he saved up money and then
started investing and like
buying property and then like fixing it
and then either
renting it or like selling it back those
contractors are sharp guys
yeah a lot of people they're they're
real sharp guys movers and champions
they always got their hands in a couple
of things are always doing real well
and they know how to do all that [ __ ] so
they have an advantage over everybody i
like that
yeah so it was it was good eventually he
like that business started doing well
so that was good and then my mom was a
lawyer in india but when she came here
her license didn't fully transfer so she
ended up working like as a
when she had us she became a part-time
paralegal okay
so your dad's in construction your mom's
a paralegal pretty good you're not owned
that's why your dad owned a business
your mom was a lawyer or worked in law
when she got here that's [ __ ]
top shelf how quickly did you get into
the um
to the house your uncle built in the
neighborhood how old were you
i was that was middle school i want to
say
okay so you had a little bit were you do
you remember the apartment
no i don't remember that apartment
because we were in a small house by then
like a small
like in the line and then they moved to
a bigger one the apartment was my
brother what do you know about this
line neighborhood ah it's no rosemont
i'll tell you that much
about i don't know shout out to jimmy's
23.
way to play inside chicago baseball that
just hit for like three people in
rosemont
chicago right now is it nice or not
i couldn't tell you never been ah it's
not bad but it's not like um
fancy you know and what about the place
where you moved into where the house was
that like is much uh fancier what
neighborhood's that
uh hawthorne woods so that's near
mr hawthorne hawthorne woods that's good
oh man i just got [ __ ] excited
it sounds like an old-timey author that
killed himself
whatever you do don't go in the hostel
woods alone at night
they say the trees can talk no thank you
uh and was that school public or private
public but it's one of the best i think
it's really good
yeah our class was like um 1 000 plus
students like 1
100 something students and are
graduating and you're graduating
because i graduated with 550. i
graduated
[Laughter]
me and the schleger twins
elmer and elmer
a thousand kids man that's a that's a
big [ __ ] so it had to be like four
thousand people
yeah yeah it was huge but it's a good
school yeah but that's trashy though man
when the school's too big
no yeah it's hawthorn still
you didn't know any but i i was glad
that i had
three we had 300 my class probably three
in each other class
it was the perfect size everybody kind
of knew each other this is what he does
though he just romanticizes
his childhood because he's never had
anything else this is the bet
how would you how do you know you
wouldn't like a thousand people in a
class you never had it you don't know
everybody
but you don't like it there's no
hometown feel it's very
like segregated like where it's like the
ap
like the college track like was all
together it was like a scene
yeah and then like the lower kids are
like you'll [ __ ] figure it out
because
yeah like some windows like they didn't
give a [ __ ] track
i've never heard it described like that
so there was kids there were some kids
in high school that were on their way to
college and there were some that
everybody knew weren't
well i mean i'm sure they were fine but
it was like definitely very much like
you didn't see kids who weren't were you
in the camp
yeah yeah why you were like the smart
kid yeah and stuff like that so it's
like you didn't really
go outside she wasn't associating with
the foleys
outside of gym class we didn't yeah you
didn't go burn frogs after school you
want to come with us
uh no i have an honors math class
okay all right thousand kids
were you a good student yeah oh i um
i had to be it was like my whole
personality it was insufferable
uh like always had to answer every
question because like
that's how i started making friends
because i was so heavily bullied that i
didn't have a personality
so i like sorry to laugh but the way i
just bluntly said i was so heavily
bullied
no i was it wasn't true and i like
didn't know how to talk to people so i
would help people with their homework so
people would have to come to me
that was like you know good you know
like people who start doing these
walls are into [ __ ] power moves
you know how like people in l.a deal
cocaine to make friends i did that with
like math quiz answers like that's
what i was listening if you wonder who
if you get on a bus at noon and you end
up in tallahassee
text my number text me 3.14 and i'll
know what you mean
and i'll call you back you were bullied
yeah oh yeah
i mean i was like pudgy i used to think
i was a fat kid and then i looked at
pictures of myself and i was like those
[ __ ] [ __ ] i wasn't even that fat
i swear to god it was a different
different in the 90s and 2000s
like if you look at george on seinfeld
he was viewed as a fat person i look at
him now i'm like dude that guy's a stunt
dude he was like a buck 45. the 90s was
just different
the 90s 2000 was just was just different
yeah
oh my goodness okay brothers and sisters
yeah i had an older brother
how old are you uh four years did you go
to the same school
were you guys ever in high school
together yes like the first my first
year there was last year there now was
he looking out for you with the bullying
your freshman year
well high school again because the
nerves were together it wasn't
really that much yeah it was more like
with like-minded people
yeah it was more in middle school that
it was like mixed with the animals over
there
you were in gen pop [ __ ] criminals
yeah i tell you what that middle school
cafeteria was a [ __ ] minefield
you gotta be real careful kids were
brutal in the 90s i remember kids
pouring chocolate milk down this one fat
kid's butt crackers
and it ruined my underwear
i never got it but when i witnessed that
i was on my guard from here on out man
i was like they ain't getting me like
that well he's just taping the back of
his pants
it was overalls every day
for the rest of the middle last man out
of every room too
[Laughter]
you go you go they called me henry the
gentleman let everybody go ahead of me
no after you please
show up to lunch early buy all the
chocolate milk
what's fully doing guy just loves
chocolate milk
he get me with that [ __ ] what uh
what's your brother do now uh he's i
think he's doing something with a.i
or i mean he's like um not talk to you
don't talk to the family that much do
you
doing something i i don't know he's
alive might have been in construction
he's uh some type of engineer i forget
which kind smart guy yeah doing well
yeah yeah
pretty good yeah pretty good
all right i think we should let's jump
in well why we're on the while we're on
the subject of school
uh what'd you get on your sats yeah oh i
didn't take them i took only the acts
what's that that's like that thing
what'd you get on the uh
i got uh 35. why didn't you take your
sats
because i didn't want to i was so that
was an option
yeah big in the midwest yeah yeah it's
30 i got 35 out of 36. so i was one
point away from up
i don't need to google that that checks
out pretty good
how many questions is it why is it why
is it only 36 points i have no idea
nah that's [ __ ] stupid um the sat out
of 2600
it sounds better i'll tell that's why it
sounds better what'd you get in your
test i got a 35. what'd you get a test i
got 2600.
that's a first of all 2400 i got to
correct you oh is it well now it's back
to 14. yeah youtube bozos
it's 38 green uh what was your gpa
um i don't remember but i was it was the
highest
i wonder you were getting bullied
i have a real attitude on her this one i
was so over
academia though because like it was so
my school was so intense that they took
away the title of valedictorian because
kids were like killing themselves
really but just for my year and i would
have been valedictorian isn't that
[ __ ]
up and then still bitter parents really
yeah and parents were so mad they put it
back but like i was the only year where
it skipped yeah you should have said you
were gonna know what are they doing
and you think you would have got it no i
know because like i didn't even know
actually this is how competitive our
school was it's like they show the gpa
range
like it's like this to this is like
whatever percent and then kids started
coming up to me and we're like you're
valedictorian and i was like what like
they figured it out and told me
but um that's how insane it was and then
by the time
and i didn't want anything to do with
academics at that point like i was kind
of doing it for the approval of my
family and to like have friends and i
was just
exhausted like at one point i told my
mom i didn't want to take that many
college level classes and she's like
what are you going to do stay home and
have babies and i was like what
like why is that the alternative those
indian parents
did not [ __ ] around when it comes to
grace
i'm not but that's the thing is they
were chill indian parents in michael
like they were indian kids who had two
parents and i was
so mad i was furious there was this one
kid named kiran whose parents were super
chilly he's like yeah bring him a b plus
they're like good enough and i was like
what what yeah wow i was so mad
um
thunder but i didn't want to take the
sats i didn't want to go to ivy league
school
i was just so overwhelmed did you go to
an ivy league school um no i think
you didn't get to put this plane into
action did you what what do you mean
what you're saying your mom let you get
away with it yeah this happened
yeah because i didn't want to go to um i
think
well because for undergrad it doesn't
matter that much it's expensive they
expected me to go on and get a phd so
like undergrad it's like okay and then
you got burned out
it was it was a lot it was [ __ ] inten
and then like because that was my whole
personality like if i didn't get
the top score i didn't know who i was so
i would like have a complete spiral
meltdown but like
yeah it was it was a lot did you take
adderall in high school
no but in college yes a lot um another
comedian was selling me
adderall in college and he's like i have
to stop because you're gonna die and
everyone's gonna be mad at me that's
literally what he said
jesus well i have to take the most out
of all of my class
i have to be devout and victorian in
adderall otherwise my parents won't love
me
holy [ __ ] but it's because i was doing
stand-up and i was in pittsburgh i ended
up in pittsburgh which was at school
uh you pet nice good school yeah they
gave me a full ride which is what i was
like [ __ ] yeah
nice um it was a game
but i traded it in for four adderall and
three open mic spots
but i would like drive up to ohio i
would drive to erie pennsylvania i was
doing stand up
where jrs oh yeah uh yeah yeah the one
where yeah
yeah um so i was driving all around and
doing all that and then i still had to
keep my grades up for my scholarship and
just because i didn't want to deal with
my family so i was like
snorting at all just like nuts like
bad you know i knew we were gonna get
here eventually
have you ever snorted adderall to pass a
test i do you do it to party and stuff
like that yeah
no [ __ ] yeah you you you were doing the
right things but you just needed to
shift your focus
dude i was so sleep deprived i started
hallucinating like i couldn't like it
was bad
like not not like full-on hallucinating
but that thing where you can't tell
what's real what so yeah where you are
yeah
um like i get that driving sometimes i'm
like how about i get here oh i hate that
you're like so tired you're like i just
missed those tails those last ten exits
what the [ __ ]
maybe it's time to pull over have a sig
or something
it's dragging a fence behind you
gang let's talk about one of our
favorite new sponsors of course i'm
talking about
helix mattress oh yeah you don't just go
in and buy one
nope all right they take the time they
want to know about you
yeah so you take the sleep quiz and you
find out how you're sleeping yeah
and they've come up with a way to
develop mattresses
for every type of person oh yeah people
who get hot at night people who get too
cool at night
and guess what they got for the big man
what's that they got the plus size
mattress out there
they've got a big hole baby they got the
soft the medium firm mattresses whatever
you need
helix has it and also we're in the
middle of a gold pandemic who wants to
go in somewhere and lay on a mattress no
are you even allowed to do that anymore
and a good night's sleep is more
important these days than ever i mean
the world's ending
at least sleep well you know what i mean
they uh they sent us one of these me and
my wife we took the helix quiz
and i was matched with the twilight
model queen size baby
must be nice pretty good comes right to
your door in a box you open it up
pops out i think it's like two hours and
you're sleeping on that bad boy
yeah so if you're looking for a mattress
go to helix take the quiz you order the
mattress that you're matched to mattress
comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to the mattress store again
no going out no none of this none of
that take the quiz
order the mattress boom mattress shows
up bada bing bada boom you're top
quality mattress you're clean living
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number
one best overall mattress pick for 2020
by gq and wired magazine i don't know
bozo publication huh that's some class
some classy literature right there yes
yes so just go to helixsleep.com
garbage take the two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you with a customized
mattress that'll give you the best
sleep of your life to boot they got a
10-year warranty
you'll get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free that's standing by your
product they'll even pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will
wow so listen guys here it is helix is
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com garbage one more time
get your phone out write it down
write it in the sand whatever you need
that's helix sleep.com
garbage for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
wow hold on there cowboys and cowgirls i
want to talk to you about one of our new
that another one of our new favorite
products here
on the old podcast it's called fume
oh baby zoom in here you know them you
love them we're talking about the
canadian made wooden inhaler
with no electronics and cores filled
with the benefits of super plants no
chemicals added all natural
fume is portable tool it's reliable it's
good for allergy relief relaxation and
an incredible nicotine replacement
i've tried it and it absolutely works
and
it fits right in your pocket yeah guys
they sent us a whole bunch of it the
guys a few
are awesome they listen to the show so
support the guys who support the show
yes they do
uh like i said they have it for
everything if you're trying to get off
the bernies which you should be doing
they got coors for that uh they have
reassurance for calming stress relief
anti-inflammatory benefits they smell so
good they got shield which is peppermint
eucalyptus clove
for immunity boosting and energy
whatever you need
they got it so check them out guys head
to breathefume.com that's
breathefumefum.com and use promo code
garbage to save 10
and breathe in the benefits of the world
super plants today guys one more time
get your pencil whatever you need write
it down that's
www.breathfume.comfumefum.com
use promo code garbage the link will be
in the description just click on it
save 10 and breathe in the benefits of
the world super plants today
now back to the show i could dude i
there was my parents never
your parents even know what an ape there
was there was your parents are like c
minus all right you're the smart one
there was such zero pressure on
academics and look how you turned out
right well i mean you just read her
impd it took 15 minutes she's a [ __ ]
worker
yours is i'm on ayg comedy podcasting
built but i'm just saying
i think they just knew from jump street
that this one's not gonna
yeah yeah for sure so that's crazy that
you [ __ ] drove yourself nuts with all
that stuff
yeah well you could see it in your
comment in
the way you're just you're working sure
like your comedy work i think is [ __ ]
bananas it is it's literally crazy it's
not healthy
like i'm definitely going to spray no
i'm going to spiral out publicly at some
point and it's going to be bad
like i know that's going to happen i'm
trying to like chill the [ __ ] out but
it's like about entering science
contests and stuff like that
i'm gonna win i'm gonna win huh man it's
cuckoo
all right let's talk some let's talk
some basics
um what was the name of the street that
you grew up on so whichever house
you were at the longest i'll let you use
i'll say
probably bingham oh no well actually hot
old barn road was probably oh i
shouldn't have said the number
we can bleep it we can believe it yeah
we'll bleep it out we'll bleep it out
that's pretty classy that's what that's
that might be one of those that's
old born road what kind of car does your
dad drive um
toyota yeah oh wait but here my mom
drives the toyota he has a subaru
subaru oh no no no mazda i'm bad with
cars it was a mazda that's what it was
uh a mazda on old barn road something's
not
gonna mark that down a mazda i don't
know anybody that drives a mazda was it
a truck
uh minivan minivan we didn't have a
construction truck for work
because at that point he wasn't doing
that at that point he had
a guy that did the contracting for him
huh look at his fingers dirty smart guy
why wasn't he driving a beamer or a
mercedes or
i think it's a cultural thing right yeah
and
typically the india the indians aren't
that flashy they're very it's very
akash said this it's very straight up
the middle reliable you know what i mean
they look value you can get a lot of you
get the same use out of a mazda that you
get out of a b
and also my parents were never like rich
you know
a lot of the money was going to property
tax you got
yeah okay what was the name of the
grocery store that your mother went to
as you were growing up uh
jewel oscar that's a very chicago toby
toby how's that check out on the scale
that's the down that's down the middle
it's it's a publix it's a harris teeter
it's it's uh
peter i don't know i don't know chicago
references with chicago
reference it's just like mccluskies you
know what i'm talking about that on
third street
those are all southern ones it's like uh
stop and shop okay classy right up the
middle
gotcha gotcha gotcha interesting did
your
your parents didn't call it jewels did
they no very classy
because [ __ ] trash bags in chicago
we're going down to jewels going out of
joel's
get the deep dishes get a frozen thing
they got the rotisserie chicken down
here i don't know how they cook it
on wednesdays um
oh yeah dude rotisserie special on
wednesdays wednesday's four dollars
did um did the house on old barn road
have a garage
yeah did you have a refrigerator in that
garage
no really yeah
well you were a one-fridge house yeah
wow huh
no ice pops no sodas no nothing like
that they just went in the freezer
yeah really were you allowed to have
that stuff when you were a kid
yeah uh yeah my dad also had like a huge
sweet tooth so i all i remember is my
mom just yelling like you're eating all
the ice cream like that was everything
i might do this was last weekend
um okay and then that garage did that
garage door have an opener
yeah ooh just like the button yeah the
clicker
everybody had the clicker in their car
did you have a car in high school no
how did you get to school uh bus yeah
your parents didn't drive you no new
ruling your parents drove you to school
you're trash
what yeah i got driven to school every
day it's crazy but you're delicious
you're a divorced dad this is high
school too
i don't know why he has to be divorced
also just my dad
i don't know why we're bringing up old
[ __ ] he's also a human being
he's also a [ __ ] taxpayer and a
business owner last time i checked
i'm a goddamn american no i've been
thinking about this that's that that's
trash
in high school
weird [ __ ] brown plastic seats that
you're sliding all over with no seatbelt
see that was fun you mixed them with
everybody can't
you you can only look you only go
exactly what you expect i think it's a
tough look if your dad's dropping you
off at school in high school
and then giving you lunch my mom did the
same thing
i wasn't waiting for the bus i said yo
todd start the car
wasn't there [ __ ] sizzling
uh yeah there was a bus that came and
got everybody we drove by those [ __ ]
poses
that's weird if i was your friend on the
bus why are you doing your mom dropping
you listen i wasn't friends with the
kids on the bus okay
i was friends with other kids that got
driven to school oh so i see what this
was you were running from a bully
super's in there taking up taking like a
[Laughter]
[Music]
chance
[ __ ] getting wedgies um would you
all sit down and have dinner together
yeah every every night yeah
no tv oh was there tv
i don't think so no i don't think there
was tv did you eat in the kitchen or the
dining room dining room
really well yeah was there a table and
like did you also have a kitchen table
no no so it was like a kitchen and then
there was like a table like a
seating area and then there was like a
fancy dining room but we ate
and like you ate in like the more
generic
in the kitchen yeah all right just say
if you're eating the dining room every
night that's
the heist class just sitting on the
opposite end yeah
yeah two candles going did you ever have
milk with dinner growing up
no yeah all right take it easy yeah she
just did she couldn't
that was a body reaction she had i can't
it's like every villain
in every movie now just drinks milk with
a straw it just
creeps me out it's true ever since hans
landa
i'll tell you what that scene in
glorious pastures makes me want a glass
of milk so bad
in the farm the nazi who murders all the
innocent people
i'll tell you as an actor he drinks a
really good glass of milk i'm sorry
i'm not connecting to the to the content
material of the script
or the character he's playing the milk
look good
[Laughter]
okay all right um growing up did your
family drink tang no
i don't think we had i think we may have
had tang like once we had those mondo
you know those mondo drinks with the
twist top off them those are good
mondo what are we talking about it was a
trashy uh
[ __ ] what was the other way that's a
those things were real garbage no those
things are plants when they come
mondo's are below those now yes mondo's
are the power aid if
if the gatorade or the skinny things
toby can you look up the oh you have the
monitors were [ __ ]
awesome what's the name the kool-aid
things the kool-aid bottles what were
they
jammers do you remember the kool-aid
james i don't know come and come in a
pouch
no those are class they look it's
plastic but it's soft plastic and it
looks like a
like a glass bottle of coca-cola these
things yeah kool-aid bursts
yeah those things are garbage no well
the mondo is the shittier version of
this
that's what you were wrong yeah they
were great they were bigger
you kids in the 90s i don't know mondo
juice here it is
uh i don't even have the wait they don't
even come up oh yeah these
look at that that's a tough look looks
like they fished out of a river
that's a bad look wow yeah and then
they discovered what happened to that
missing girl
mine's got a tooth in it those things
you definitely bought warm they weren't
they weren't in the in the cooler they
weren't in the freezer section no they
were not
your groceries freezers that's trashy so
that was the
that was the drink they had that a lot
yeah any frozen orange juice at your
house
frozen orange juice i don't think so no
okay
fridge very interesting
i like it at any point did your family
use i can't believe it's not butter
no okay we used butter and indian butter
ghee oh i just might my girl my wife got
me on the ghee that [ __ ] is top notch
first of all it's 35 bucks a jar
she's like go get the ghee i'm like what
the [ __ ] but my mom didn't use butter
that much she always tried to cook
healthy so most of the time it was olive
oil
i was trying to substitute that [ __ ]
class
have you ever eaten a hard-boiled egg in
public yeah oh yeah they're great
that's not a good one what was your
lunch in high school do you remember
my mom would pack it so it was always a
mess um
sometimes she would just do you know
what was the worst is when she would try
to combine leftovers and then just call
it something new
that's bad like that's a bad look when
you open that up you open that bag up
but
i left this bro i'll never forget her
version of an indian burrito it was just
like
leftover indian food and a tortilla it
was the most disgusting i was like what
did you do oh my god
it was not great um but we also got
lunchables sometimes
all right okay okay back and forth in
the fire
luncheons we never got lunchables oh man
they're expensive
yeah well they're saving money on the
mondo
i'm not going name brand i'm reading
even the wikipedia on
mondo says it resembled kool-aid burst
[Music]
you can't send your kids to school with
leftovers though that was that i would
i would have marched right out of that
cafeteria stolen a bus drove home
and [ __ ] had it had at it with my
mother oh buddy the lunch the leftovers
were the least of my problems
she's getting swirly what are you
talking about she's happy to get a break
and eat her
indian burrito a fresh sandwich and a
cupcake and a can of soda or something
like that
we would get like zebra cakes and stuff
like those
little dubbies with like the rainbow
those are the [ __ ] things were all right
okay okay
um do you wear pajamas yeah you do
you put on like a pair of matching
pajamas yeah before you go to bed yeah
that's cool that's pretty [ __ ] classy
that's
classy
i'm always that's hawthorne heights
right there that is
also a forest or what because i'm all
about that these days i don't do it
personally
yeah you wore pajama pants into here the
other day
cause i'll sweat but i think it's classy
that people
that when i like how you're getting into
the idea of people wearing pajamas
well at the end of the night you're like
you brush your teeth and all that stuff
you're changing your pajamas
maybe you have a robe on in your
slippers i like that's classy as [ __ ]
you don't wear [ __ ] pajamas sleep in
your jeans dude
yeah yeah i got [ __ ] to do gotta wake up
ready dawg
do you sleep with socks on no uh but
it's i think that's also part of growing
up in a conservative household it's like
you can't just be like sleeping in your
underwear
or some [ __ ] like what if i have to that
was always great do you ever go to
someone's house they like where they're
under like kids come down in their
boxers and [ __ ] you're like yo
dude [ __ ] put it away will you my
mom's making pancakes not at sleepovers
and [ __ ] like that but i sleep in my
skivvies
that's how i operate yeah i'm saying
when you're living with your parents
you're a 45 year old man
you can do it now walking around in your
weighties yeah grabbing an oj
holy [ __ ] if you sleep in your socks
you're a [ __ ] serial killer i don't
know
dude if you sleep in your socks that is
so trashy i'll get into bed sometimes
and forget to take them off
and then i just do the little thing with
my feet scooch them out find them in the
morning but down by the
end of the bed okay i don't know you
could
i mean this guy i thought we were sure
yeah i know how you take your socks off
when you're in bed
um are any of your bills on autopay yeah
what ones all of them all of them wow
that's 69 episodes of jim jefferson
you gotta have a little bit of cash you
got to be doing all right you're very
successful
auto pay you pay your credit card at the
end of every month
really do you own an american express
card you pay my credit card
what's your social security number wait
you have an american express card
what color is it uh gold the one for the
flights
that's the limit on that we talked about
this stuff all the time oh i have no
idea i should probably i wasn't
interested she was just like wow
these these guys are getting super
[ __ ] up oh we asked this [ __ ] all the
time
mine's can i get a rounding number from
you mine's currently 200 foley's is 500.
five bills baby
that's what our credit limits are not
showing off that's patreon.com
folks are you garbage what about do you
know what your frequent flyer miles are
up to right now uh
i think it's like 10 000. i don't know
did you try a thousand that's it
i got nine with hawaiian airlines i
travel but i've also used them like as
soon as i can get a ticket
too all right pretty sharp
when you travel on the plane will you
bring food on the plane
uh sometimes what kind of food are we
talking here
i mean it's the airport so whatever the
hell i can get will you get like a
burger and bring it on will you eat
would you eat like hot
food smelly food probably she was eating
indian burritos
what are you talking about that's tough
that's not classy
bro the worst was i was on a like a
chinatown bus to boston and this dude
whipped out a full low main container
and just started scarfing
it was so gross there was so much sauce
ah that was one of my questions too when
was the last time you won a mega bus
um i want to say it was like i was had
to be living in new york
and like on my way to like boston or
something a couple years ago yeah yeah
okay that's what makeup even
have a little bit of cash a lot of
people in new york take mega bus
i like megabytes because you're stuck
like a lot nobody has a car
yeah amtrak the other way is like 500
bucks to get anywhere on amtrak
megabus bathroom is what created
coronavirus as far as i'm concerned
he's [ __ ] up dude that whole time i've
never had to use a mega bus bathroom
thank god oh i have
but yeah will you take your shoes off on
an airplane no
never no neck pillow yes okay
eye mask um i have it but i very rarely
aisle cedar window uh depends if it's
like
early morning and i'm gonna be sleeping
i'll take the window so i don't get
bothered when people get up to go to the
bathroom
but if it's like midday or something
i'll take the aisle because i'm antsy
yeah you know i got i gotta have the
idea experienced travelers yeah gotta be
moving
sign a class right there um do you
prefer dunkin donuts or starbucks
um i don't like they're both too
expensive
like i like either making it myself or
going down to a boat if you live in
queens you can get like a dollar bodega
coffee
yeah yeah yeah so i think that's better
because i'm like it's the same [ __ ]
although if i am like feeling like
spending money then i like starbucks
cold brew
but i don't get it often yeah do you
ever use any recycled
glass containers to have coffee or
water in or something uh well that's all
my my boyfriend
owns all the dishes so he has mason jars
that's a trashiest statement i think
we've ever heard on the show
my boyfriend owns all the dishes yeah
what the [ __ ]
we'll be cooking i'm taking the dishes
oh yeah if he leaves me i have nothing
ah
i got nothing i owe nothing i got an
empty apartment uh no because i was like
50 50 between new york and la for like
several years during the gym jeffree
show
yeah and so like i got rid of everything
and i was just living out of two
suitcases and then like oh this is
probably the trashiest thing i ever did
i initially i was living in this
apartment because i was broke and then i
stayed there because it was so cheap
but i was living in jackson heights i
had five roommates my rent was four
hundred dollars
jesus i 1000 got what i paid for it like
at one point somebody pooped in the
hallway and nobody could figure out who
did it
hold on one of the roommates yeah in the
apartment hallway or in the hallway of
the building no in the apartment hallway
like on their way to the bathroom
uh craigslist people crazy people and
then like the
lady and her boyfriend who were in
charge were like these super religious
taiwanese people
and like uh the wi-fi network was
preparing yourself for the day jc
returns like
there was let's talk about playing it
cool bro there was a good thing
lyric jesus they were actually really
nice i was kind of scared of him at
first but
uh i ended up having to move out in an
emergency
and my rent was like month to month uh
because it was part railway
uh railroad so i had to walk through
another person's apartment or
room to get to my room sure and uh it
was fine you know there was always like
you know
a little bit of tension between whoever
was there but it was totally fine until
this one girl moved in and definitely
like i think it was the first time
because she's right around that age
where mental illness starts
uh exhibiting so she started showing
signs where like she's like you're
moving things around my room and i'm
like
bro like why i'm not a nymph like i have
to go to work in the morning i come back
from shows i'm not like putting your
bottle from one shelf together
in your picture for anything yeah and
she was like
threatening she was like if i don't find
my cell phone it's going down and then
she found her cell phone but i was still
really scared of her so i would
i'm scared of her now dude i would walk
through my room in a hoodie and i had
like a full knife like it tucked into
the sleeve of my hoodie
until i could get out of comedy baby
that was like the rest of the month and
then i was like bouncing around from
place to place so i got rid of all my
[ __ ]
and then i was that's how i ended up
sleeping on garbage bags and then i was
like
50 50 between new york and la and still
everything i owned was in two suitcases
so by the time my boyfriend like moved
me in with him everything was his life
[Applause]
he was like fema [ __ ]
shout out to this guy oh it's crazy yeah
i lived at derek's place at one point
uh i got one when was the last time you
slept in a bunk bed
oh right now uh what
the airbnb i'm staying at is it's
actually nice but it's a bunk bed for
some reason
no no so it can't be actually nice then
subaru is it a is it a queen bunk bed or
is it like a single
single bed do they make queen sized bunk
beds where the [ __ ] are you staying
[Applause]
yeah but it's like it's not far from
here like it's a really good location
i don't know if you've been in new york
for that long this location stinks
i mean we walk by people shooting up
every single day oh yeah for sure
there's been several people
outside of the apartment building
i'm the neighborhood guy i'm like i'm
very concerned so hold on so you're in a
you're in a one-bedroom airbnb well in
the bedroom
hold on i don't think that's correct
well because it's like uh
top the apartment is it's like a top and
a bottom and there's a girl in the
bottom and i'm on the
top so when you got it on airbnb did you
click entire place
no shared room um well it's in a shared
room because she has her own space
downstairs and then i have my thing
upstairs
there's no door between you there's like
a staircase with a curtain
okay it's the same [ __ ] [ __ ] there's
a staircase
get get an airbnb for yourself you're
doing good
bro you should see where i'm hotel
tonight it's like 99 bucks a night
it wasn't bad i'm happy with the place i
was like you're used to sleeping with
[ __ ] crazy people in a railroad
apartment yeah with a [ __ ] knife on
you yeah solving poop mysteries
by the way my money's on the chick that
you described as having mental illness
no i'm pretty sure it was there did you
move my poop i knew you moved my poop
who touched my poop that was a [ __ ] in
the hallway an hour ago where is it
i know it's you super man and so but
in your section of this airbnb in your
bedroom
the only bed in there is a bunk bed yeah
how about i can't even how insane is
that i asked that question and she's
sleeping in a [ __ ] bug bed
[Laughter]
that's insane like who would that
what is it like an airbnb for two for
two runaway eight-year-olds
there's no mattress on the top
oh oh my god that's what
dude that's the combination of two very
tough looks a bunk belt
a bunk bed and a bunk bed with no top
bunk yeah
it's easier to chain people to it
holy [ __ ] jesus
there's something even worse i used to
do when i came here but i feel like i
shouldn't say this story out loud
because it's just like embarrassing what
was i doing
ship it [ __ ] um okay so
when i was in between places and i was
bouncing from place to place like
i stared at lily's place i stared at
derek's place this was right after i had
to leave because that roommate was
threatening to kill me
and i was like one does i kept finding
these great deals i was like well i
could sign something but this is so
cheap and then i kept taking things for
a month at a time
out of my mind there's only two corpses
that's a great deal it's just fine
you're very like even if you have the
money
you still like to do things in a
response
getting better i think it was just like
being traumatized from like immigrant
parents who would not spend money of
course of course and then
not having money for so many years yeah
of course like when i first came to new
york and then just being like it's gonna
run out and then what do i do i'm
homeless because my family hates me
uh so i was just like panicking and then
breezed over that but
i'm i'm worth right now but i'm getting
better at like spending money on stuff
but it's like
i still have that mentality we're like
this is a deal you live below your means
and
yeah i respect that normally do every
now and then i'm like what the [ __ ] did
you just buy
uh but i bunk beds
there was um i was tweeting about like
um that roommate being uh
crazy you know and wanting uh you know
scaring the [ __ ] on me and this a guy
who like hangs around comedy
is like hey i have a spare bedroom uh
plenty of comics have crashed here this
is blah blah blah like you can stay
[ __ ] set up as long as you want i
don't know who hangs around
comedy he's like a comedy super fan
you've seen those people you know
uh yeah so he was like a guy you want to
live with
and he was so nice for so long and i was
like okay and then it was a luxury
apartment on the upper east side with a
spare bedroom but his mom was also there
he lived there as well yeah yeah so it
would be like his mom this dude and then
i would come and crash
especially when i was back and forth
between new york and l.a i was like this
solves that
um and i was like whatever was it his
room or an extra bedroom extra bedroom
so there's an extra bedroom in this
apartment yeah in this big luxury
apartment
yeah that this comedy fan said you can't
stay in so i was like his mother
yeah yeah he's a he's like a grown man
yeah
30s 40s i think he's late 30s maybe in
his 40s all right
yeah he's for sure listening to this
yeah oh god i hope not
[Laughter]
but um long story short
he was super nice and i don't even know
like i didn't catch him
doing anything i just i just what the
[ __ ]
i just saw him walk into the room i was
staying butt naked once
and i was like okay that's where the ac
is
is he touching my stuff what's going on
but i panicked and immediately left
like that night i was like i need to get
the [ __ ] out of there you were in the
room
no um okay i put cause i noticed stuff
around my room was like moving and then
i saw his glasses with her so i put a
webcam
on the door and so it recorded him
walking in naked and then i was like
what is happening
dude what the [ __ ]
it's like 127 episodes i'm speechless i
think for the first time
this is [ __ ] bonko's i know i
shouldn't have i shouldn't have been
there and i don't know that he was doing
anything creepy he was his place
i wasn't there he was just walking
around naked in his own place yeah you
can do that but
i'm sure but it was enough to scare me
to be like get the
[ __ ] out of there that was enough to
scare jesus in fact he's living with his
mom
i'm like i have a job what is wrong with
me um she's
killing me
but it was like free and it was such a
nice place
yeah there was a bad situation yeah i
know
i know crazy what was the mom like she
was so nice she was dead
i don't know she just sat in a rocking
chair all day put sunglasses on
but that's the thing is i really liked
the mom like i liked them so it was just
like i probably should have asked
questions but i didn't i was just like
give me the [ __ ] out something
just your son a creepo
[ __ ] yeah that scared me i was like what
get out
get out now man something else
yeah that was bad that was like real
dirtbag [ __ ] cause i
i think i was just so used to like
living like that gotcha
even when i started making money i
didn't stop and it's like
yeah that's not okay like you need to
because you end up in situations where
your roommate wants to kill you and
there's a naked guy in your bedroom
i mean if you're even living in a place
where like i think i should set up a
webcam to see what's happening when i'm
not here
that's enough sign to get the [ __ ] out
of there yeah it's because like
it's because you have a if you have a
sense where you're like i need to set up
a camera when i'm gone
well there's something going on i
wouldn't have even done that if it
wasn't for my boyfriend because i was
talking to him and i was like i found
his glasses in my room is that
weird and then my boyfriend literally
said that this was the first thing he
said off the hip he's like the only
reason a man takes his glasses off is to
put underwear on his face and i was like
what pretty good point i always think
mine are aware
on his i was like that's which is
upsetting because he wears glasses i was
like wait what
your boyfriend i was like wait what have
you been doing when you take your
glasses off
so i've heard but i was like that's an
insane statement but it made me feel
like scared enough to put the website i
think he
i don't know i can't know that so i
don't want to put that on that dude i
just want to say like it did creep me
out enough just having a naked roommate
to be like i think that's enough
finding yeah why would you be taking
your glasses off
but it's like i don't know what he was
[ __ ] you know he still had some stuff
in there i don't want to
i'm not going to make any assumptions
all i can say is the facts i'm going to
be very weak
assumptions
um have you ever seen either one of your
parents get thrown in a pool
no my mom would murder my dad uh
anyone in your family have a customized
license plate no
any runaways in your family uh clearly
[Laughter]
any other runaways in your family not
that i know of but i don't know my
family's super well because most of them
are in india
you know okay have you or any member of
your family ever had to hire
a private investigator i don't think so
not that i know of again
um okay have you ever had a pet bird no
what was the pet situation growing up i
wanted uh i wanted pets really bad my
mom was terrified of animals like
so scared so i got fish and like we had
those for a little bit and then i kept
wanting to get another thing that was
like a little bit higher up than fish
but it could never happen
uh we got fish and then there was like a
tiny little crab that was really cute
and the [ __ ]
the pet store said that he was totally
fine with the fish we put him in and
this [ __ ] started skewering and
just eating fish yeah he's a crab that's
what they do
yeah but the pet store employee totally
didn't lie to us and my dad caught it on
camera and i was like what happened to
my fish and he's like oh you gotta see
this and then
show me the video wait your dad set up a
camera too
what the [ __ ] with the aggro they
don't [ __ ] trust nobody with the
audio video equipment
yeah i'm surprised that when you walk in
here you're like oh you guys film this
because if not i got my cameras with me
i could set them up
i swear i honestly feel like more of a
creep that dude was probably just
chilling walking around naked and like
offering me a free place and now i'm
just ruining his reputation
you do have a tripod in your bag right
now jesus
ah man have you ever used a chilled
salad fork
no hmm do you currently own any
champagne flutes
i think my boyfriend might have one i
don't know there's this guy sounds good
again i know him he's not
yeah no he's not he's just much more of
an adult than i am
hmm all right have you ever waited in a
line to shop on black friday
yes for what oh i don't even know i just
wanted to see the deals
i can't go kicking tires on black friday
i got a good deal on a big steak knife
and a webcam
um when was the last time you were at a
marshalls tj maxx or a ross dress for
last my god
probably a few weeks ago ain't nothing
wrong with it
it's trashy but did your father coach
any little league teams that you weren't
on
oh god no he could barely he would not
he would not do that no coaching okay
solid i mean we're coming
we're at trash right you've already
entered the town
of garbage i believe
what what tipped what's what she's got
nothing going in her favor
that she was smart for a couple of hours
back in middle school
what was your first concert oh i went to
a post malone concert um just recently
yeah it was your first comment yeah
well because too busy hitting the books
[Laughter]
that's literally what happened is like
in high school i was you know i wasn't
allowed to [ __ ] go anywhere and then
in college i was snorting at all like
doing stand-up and like trying to keep
my grades up and then
uh i was doing stand-up all night every
night and i just was
didn't have any friends and then um like
real quick it was like
i still have to like i'm like bad at
being social because like my childhood
was so
stunted you know so i'm like i've gotten
a lot better at talking to people and
like hanging out and being a human being
but like
even recently derek was like we're going
down the center i was like i'm kind of
tired he's like yeah of course super
doesn't hang and then i like turned into
my high school stuff i was like i can
linger
i can hang i'll do your homework i'll do
your man homework postman
how was the concert pretty good well
okay this is embarrassing my friend
had um an extra ticket so he got two
and i had shows and he was like if you
can come to any part of the concert just
show up so i came for like half of the
last song
jesus christ but it was so yeah it
really sounds like you're learning how
to be
more social i'm going to check 35
seconds to just post one okay and i know
you had a huge book bag on you when you
showed up yeah
yeah with a bunch of stuff i actually
changed to a giant purse that is
technically luggage uh because
monroe kept making fun of me for having
a backpack
i bought a purse and i stopped wearing
uh new balance sneakers
now i wear boots
you're killing me have you ever okay
i can't ask that she knows what it was a
concert question oh
i looked at it um
did any of your bathrooms ever have
carpeting growing up
no any padded toilet seats no did you
have a pool
no do you currently own a blow up
mattress
no but i was looking into getting one
you currently have a storage unit
somewhere
uh no i just got rid of mine
when i moved into like uh because my me
and my boyfriend moved in together and
then i was like
and where are you where did your
boyfriend live he was in los angeles oh
you're
so you're you're based out of l.a yeah
yeah okay
buddy i don't know what to tell you this
kids
[Laughter]
yeah i mean she seeks out dangerous
living situations no now i'm doing
better
[Laughter]
she stays she goes by herself she's good
with audio video equipment
she knows how to use a knife she was
snorting at her all the studying
norton adderall to study goes to a half
apparently
tonight is going to rest her head in a
bunk bed
man that's garbage soup
through and through i was shocked gee i
did not see this going this way
i knew we'd get you a little bit with
the comedy stuff and
but man setting up webcams
yeah that was bad i feel bad about doing
that i should have just like
naked
you shouldn't have been living there in
the first place i was so and there was
one point where his family went on
vacation so it was just me in a luxury
apartment
cat sitting i was like this is the
[ __ ] greatest yeah that's what you
think there was people in the closet
i'm here all alone yeah that's what they
want you to think subs they were
charging two grand a pizza
through the painting eyeballs following
you around [ __ ] the apartment
it feels like someone else is in this
apartment there is
subagawa ladies and gentlemen oh man
what a [ __ ] home run of an app
garbagio crazy subs what do you got
coming up you want the folks to know
about
um i would say just follow me on
instagram
at supah that's also very bad
s-u-v-h-a-h-a
on twitter at suba um yeah watch the
plan b movie on hulu cool fantastic very
funny subagawa ladies and gentlemen
kippy what do you got for him out there
uh you know as always review subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube
patreon.com and the live shows guys we
have [ __ ]
so many live shows we have chicago
there's still some tickets left indy
atlantic city's about to sell out we
have rhode island boston
cleveland columbus magooby's factory
and we're adding more technology stuff
is coming soon get
involved yeah come see us gang we love
you we'll see you next week
peace